Ron DeSantis, in his latest proof of
being completely not ready for prime time,
ended up massively triggered at his own press
conference here. We're going to look at a couple
of clips. And the story here is this guy is so
not ready or able to handle a protracted and and
ugly national. Primary campaign against Donald
Trump. He's just not ready. I don't know if
he ever will be. He's so uncharismatic. He's so
trigger level that I just don't know that he can
ever do it. Here, DeSantis cuts off a reporter who
tries to ask him about his anti-trans policies,
and DeSantis yells out how many people here are
paid or something like that. See that You can
justify it. Do you think American voters won? Now,
many of these people were paid to come. I mean,
like, honestly, it's like, seriously, some
of this stuff is just totally manufactured.
And when you talk to people and I know, like
people in your industry will dress it up with
a euphemism and they'll say it's health care to
cut off the private parts of a 14 or 15 year old.
That is not health care. That is mutilation.
Whoa. And we're standing up against that. Guys
off his rocker. And so when we're standing
up against that, we're protecting these
kids. We had Chloe Cole. We've had other people
who who went through this when they were minors.
Now they're older and it's like the biggest
regret of their life. They feel like that
they were manipulated. I understand there's some
physicians that are very ideological about it,
but the fact is people go through a lot
when they're teenagers. You grow out of
it most of the time in these situations. 80,
90% resolves by the time you get there. Sweden,
these European countries that went down this road
have done a big U-turn. They said this is not good
medical practice and so they don't do it anymore.
So all we're doing is is doing what's right.
The idea that this would have been something
that people would have been it would have even
been controversial even like ten years ago,
would not have been something that anybody
would have said. Well, you know, what's funny is
ten years ago, the right wasn't obsessed with it.
The treatments have gotten better. But ten years
ago the difference was the right wasn't obsessed
with it and in some senses it was actually
a better process to go through and get the
treatment that people wanted to get and that they
believe was right for them in consultation with
their doctors. DeSantis asked about, Are you going
to run in 2024 or not? And he says relatively soon
he's going to get on that relatively soon. You
have to say about it Republican colleagues and
colleagues saying that would be political
malpractice not to for the White House.
Well, look, I mean, I think that I was starting
to get asked about this actually years ago.
Right. But it's like, look, I was I was in my
first term as governor. We were doing good things.
A lot of the stuff I was doing that I think put
me on the map was because I was getting criticized
for it, especially during COVID. Right. He didn't
want to be in the spotlight. He was just doing
the right things. And people started paying
attention at that. Florida handled it right
and then many other things there. But I was like,
look, the end of the day, you know, as a leader,
you get things done, very important. But you also
got to show take that case to the voters and you
got to be able to get some support down on the on
the election front. And so I felt very confident
going into November 22, we were going to do very
well. But you really had to put put up or shut
up on that. And so we did that. And I think that
that was something that was really significant.
And then people have been asking a lot after that.
This is all him pretending like he never really
was looking to run. But everybody just came to him
and they were so impressed. But I also understood
that we had this opportunity here to be able to
really, really do a lot of great stuff. And I've
always said that we're going to see this through,
and that's what we're going to do. You know what
happens in the future? The people will we'll get
on that relatively soon. I mean, there's just
you know, you either got to put up or shut up on
that as well. So what's weird is if he says he's
going to see this through, that suggests that
he would stay for the whole gubernatorial term.
But clearly, if he's going to run
in 2024, that's not going to happen
unless with the law change. He's actually going
to try to be a functional governor. And I don't
know what the guy's planning. It's all
crazy. It's all really, really crazy.
And of course, that term wouldn't be over if
he became president. He would end up leaving. I
don't know what he means by. We're going to see it
through. There was then he wrapped up with talking
about cutting off private parts, which is a
classic that they now are in love with. Repeating
over and over again are prohibited. Doing things
like double mastectomies. They prohibited doing
things, you know, with with male private parts
that are very graphic. They prohibited pumping
these miners with puberty blockers pumping not
something that that that it's appropriate. So
I think those are appropriate guardrails. Look,
there are some parents that this is something that
that they want to go down that road. But I think
a lot of parents, you know, they just want what's
best for their kid. Their kid may be going through
something. So then they'll go to a physician and
the physician is pushing this stuff on the family.
And that's just that's wrong. And so we're happy
that that we were able to do that. Remember that
they've still not demonstrated to my satisfaction,
certainly, that physicians are pushing things
on people for a lot of these folks explaining
options that exist, they say that's a form
of pushing. I understand some of those same
activists were upset about the death penalty
for raping the minors under 12. Why are you
upset about that? Is that really the hill that
you want to die on? I think some of these people
that particularly the serial abusers of these
kids, I think the only appropriate punishment
is capital punishment in those situations.
Kill him. He's saying kill them. Is he talking
about doctors? Who is he talking about? It's
just just a little bit vague, so you can't be
totally sure. So we were right to do that. And
we'll continue to continue to do what's right.
So. All right, everybody. God bless. Thanks so
much. God bless you. Everybody. Okay. Yeah. We're
going to kill doctors. Thank you very much. Now,
the polling keeps getting worse. For DeSantis,
it's not dramatically worse. This is a 2024
Republican nomination poll and it actually has
a chart. You see that? The second line here,
this DeSantis line. It peaked in mid-February
and then got almost back up there in late March.
But there's been this pretty significant decline,
quite frankly. The decline started right before
Trump got arrested and then did get arrested.
Continuing to kind of stick between DeSantis
was between 23 and 24 for a while in the primary
polling. Remember, this is against Trump. He's
now down between 22 and 23. So the polling is
getting worse, not dramatically worse, but it
really doesn't seem like this guy has what it
takes and it's so easy to get under his
skin. I hope he does run because I think
it's better for the Democratic nominee and it's
worse for DeSantis and it's worse for Trump.